trong suốt hơn năm năm kể từ khi thích lập quan hệ ngoại giao ngày 18 xong năm
1.5 bệnh lâm, 2.5 bún đáp nền tảng bứng chắc cho quan hệ sông phương
như giữa lên có thể mạnh về giống công nghệ sau tu hệ quán trị chủ exa trị bàn đúng nghiệp
phát thả thấp, 2.5 bệnh đăng bờ giống hợp tắc về đúng nghiệp thương mạnh, thích ứng biến đổi
khi hậu và thích chừng các món, gắn với mục tiêu tăng chừng xanh của biệt nâm
như giữa lên cũng luôn là đối tác hợp tắc phát triển hiệu quả tất chung vào những luyện vực
đúng giữa cộng tắc động lâu dài như giáo dục đau tạo như lực
đông nghiệp cân nghệ cào và ứng phó viên độ kí hậu.
Chúng thầm cấp nhà nước lên này của tổn biệt hư chủ tính nước tổn lâm tới như giữa lên
khẳng định chính xe nhất quán của Việt Nam có chẳng quan hệ về như giữa lên
một lối tác thân thiệt, giáo triển năng và chia sẻ nhiều điểm tương đồng
với Việt Nam tại cú tụt năng thả vị dân.
Đồng thời là dụm móc quan chẳng được quân khổ quan hệ độ tắc chứ lực quan giệp Việt Nam
và điều gì lên phát triển mạnh mẽ thực chất nhiều quả hư nước trong giờ đó mới.